uh i'm fahim tandevalo
i work for wolfram and this talk is
going to be about data fees and wolfram
finance platform
and we're going to talk about bloomberg
link
and reuters link together and
how the integration of it works
in mathematica and the usefulness of it
and bloomberg reuters
okay so what we'll go over here is
configuration because
you're going to connect to the outside
world here reuters and bloomberg they
have own preferences to connect to their
service
so we'll go with that then we'll go with
the syntax
of how you're going to make those
requests in mathematica
using wolfram language we'll talk about
the real time feeds
the output time series charting because
these are very useful
features of the wolfram language and
then the repair generation and how all
these things come together in the
finance platform
so over here there is a small
configuration you just put it once
you put in your host you put in your
request timeouts
and then it stays on the disk
that means once you have configured it
it's done you never have to
change your sessions or you restart
mathema
mathematica it will still work
okay so these are some of the queries
that you'll make
to the reuters service and in the
sentence you'll see that
when you're connecting to the bloomberg
you're using specific
names ibm unequity which is
nysc and ibm.n when you're doing
reuters and px underscore lost is the
closing price
of that instrument
so let's see so you get
we will talk about the output a bit
later and then you can do
from
and you'd all the connection is also
automatic
so when you say as bloomberg will
connect to bloomberg automatically
and you don't have to give it all the
time only in rare occasions will people
be using both sources
so in that case you'll just be able to
get rid of that
option and keep going on
and here we'll talk a little bit about
the
output this is the raw tick data from
10th on october 17th 10 30 to 10 31.
i can make that query again
it will take a little bit time
oops
there you go sometimes it turns out
okay what this table is showing
is all the events that happen between
that minute
how many bids were there how many people
put in
what value they were asking for this
equity and at
what price did the equity
got traded and the size is the volume so
500
shares got traded at 181.9 dollars
okay so this is absolute raw data
in data set format
and this is another query that you can
make to bloomberg
what it will give you is the bar data so
in from
10 30 to 10 31 in that minute
at the beginning of that minute was the
price so that's the open
and that minute was the highest price
for the equity low
close and the volume that got traded
and the value it's volume times the
average value
now here's things get
cute
you have to make two queries to get the
average data
that is the bar data open high log close
or you can make another query which is
just raw data and use
the built-in functionality of the
language
the data set language to make
the market data called the average data
and this can be done locally you don't
have to make another query to bloomberg
to get that data
and it's very simple
i can just i i took the raw data that
was in the previous slide
right here
and i grouped them
bid ask and trade now because we asked
for the trade price
here from bloomberg we're going to
compare the results
that we get using data set queries on
raw data
and directly from blue back so as you
can see that
trade total and i do a total
which is a built-in language function
and your size on it and it's
860. and you can see
that's the 860. so very compact
things and you can the reason i'm
emphasizing this is because
bloomberg and reuters they have a coder
on the queries
they have many fields and you don't want
to make so many calls you may
be interested in different fields from
bloomberg and you don't want to run out
of your code here
and there is the overhead of asking and
the process of making the connection
overhead of
that happens on the wire this happens
locally
i'll talk about the real time a little
later
but here's another thing
historical data which
it's very useful when you're trying to
do back testing and your procedures
and the language is immensely powerful
in using
and making queries on this and here i'll
do
this is year to date data and
the syntax is rather compact and it's
very nice that you give
instruments which is right over here
and properties that you wish to have
open
lost price high low and the volume
and we want
from the beginning of the year to i
could have done
today but markets have not closed yet
so i'll do yesterday and it's rather
readable
and date object it will just understand
that okay you're trying
from the beginning of the year and
let me run this query in real time
oh i should explain what the split is
apple split this year
so we'll have to make adjustment for
those
and otherwise it will give us 500 or
whatever the price was in the beginning
or until may when it did split
so there we have the data and you can
make similar queries with reuters
but the instruments and the fields
change a little bit
but the concept is exactly the same
okay
now every time you get a historical data
few things you would like to do is get
the time series out of it right
and with data set and the query language
that
goes along with it makes it very very
easy and all here i'm doing is look
i want the microsoft data and i want the
date and the closing price so i can
get the histogram or the time series for
it
i'll just delete this
it did change okay
and then other things that you might be
interested
as in the trading charts
okay
and notice that we are not making any
new queries here
everything happens locally and
just i'm selecting the microsoft
instrument and i'm giving
date open high low close which are
actually the names of the columns that
we received
in the data set above open highly close
and
that's how i'm constructing this trading
chart in a very quick manner
then
okay so another thing you could do is
just group things by
instruments and then by date and get the
time series offered
and that's the query that's it you're
done
and you get all the time series
and okay so just to show you that this
is actually
you can interpolate january 1st
now january fourth was the weekend
yes january 4th was the weekend and
it will actually compute and interpolate
what the price was on the weekends
if it is computable
then we have scoring functions now
because we have made the data set
flat so there is no introduction of
hierarchy
it is very easy to make simple queries
interesting queries that
okay on what day was a particular
instrument
at its best so
apple closed and this is the query
that you can make i'm grouping
it by instruments and then
getting the maximum scoring it by the
closing price
and i get the date and here is the
because i want to do it on a i want the
date over here is that
if i wanted other data i can just
do this
so
and you get the volume if you were
interested in that
and we can apply functions to it also
directly like group by instrument i want
the mean standard deviation and change
and there you have it so apple changed
a dollar 73 cents and so on and so forth
and these are the mean
and closing prices and that's you have
created a new data set and you can make
different queries using that this was
very very interesting like
i wanted to compute the 30-day moving
average
bloomberg computes it for you you can
fetch it directly
and i try to do the same thing and the
simplest thing that occurred was
initially i tried
date plus today minus 30 and
you can create this and okay
touch
okay so it gives you when you do just 30
date plus today minus 30 it gives you
tuesday 23rd
but those are not 30 days business days
right
and so when you're computing
different answers one is business day
one is the other thing
and
you can 30 day business days ago
you get this data and then you compare
it
directly from the bloomberg data you can
make this direct query
use your code again and it's an
agreement one
apple was 103 moving average for 30 days
and we have the same values for all of
them
and you can do some more fun queries a
little bit
so
i wanted to figure out what is a good
day to trade a particular
equity and
because our data set allows it and our
language allows grouping by day name so
um here i'm concerned with thursday
friday saturday sunday um
business days okay and
it will give me yes
grouped so after that you can compute
okay i want the mean price standard
deviation for it
and i can do that also excellent
okay so something is
not showing properly but that's
formatting
that i can get okay these are the stats
on thursday for all the equities and you
get the main prices
then okay fine looking at it doesn't
look
very nice so we can do a list plot and
that's it
you just do a stats all apple use you're
given the keys
and the column you want and you do a
less line plot on it
and it seems like thursday friday
monday monday is a good day
tuesday not so good and wednesday
better okay
so
okay
okay so
thursday friday monday and
wednesday is a good day to trade for
apple
now
you can do this query
now this is a smaller data set
um okay here's the interesting thing
so i figured fine i'm getting all this
average for the whole year up to today
but can i predict that is monday tuesday
mondays and wednesday a good day to
trade for apple or sell them
so i created a smaller data set up to
only
february so that's what it means i'm
going to select
from the data that i got up to
the date of february 1st
and that's that query
and i can do exactly the same thing and
it seems even though the plots are a bit
skewed because you have the small amount
of data
monday is still the good date
to sell your apple shares if you want to
that is
okay so that's a bit of
fun with that
and then the repair generation we have
this capability of making your own
templates and it will generate a report
for yourself
and this is the demo of that so you can
just say
i've already created the template and i
don't think i may have time for that
so author stocks name
and microsoft equity so i can
initialize that and
i'll create the document
and hopefully there you go and you have
this
document created for you
and within a couple of lines
you can actually export it to
the cloud this finished so
which is nice hopefully my session has
not expired
there you have it it's in the cloud in
the web browser
and you can take a look at it oh
and it gives you the time also this was
nice
what time was that yeah exactly
good and
all right so i'm going to go quickly to
the real-time data
and over here
you have made the query or
this is the sub things you want in real
time
and if the markets are still running
you might be able to see something oh
they change okay
so it's real time for
and you can do the same with
reuters
so hopefully
i should have put in a volume over here
oh okay and
so that was pretty much the whole
integration with world from language and
outside services for financial purposes
and so we have a powerful query very
compact
and user friendly syntax we get
time series and charting capabilities
right out of the box
and integration with the cloud
everything in one go
and i don't think i ever wrote anything
long or any clever thing so which makes
it very very nice and
it prevents you from using your
subscriptions too much
within the language and
i think that's a very good thing and we
all of this
does come with finance platform few
things may change
it's still under discussion but you can
check out the website a little bit
if i can start my firefox
so this is a product in existence we
already have
bloomberg link out there we are
introducing reuters link
with it and that's it
and i think i'm out of time